one of my favorite parts of this job is
meeting extraordinary people doing
extraordinary things it is such a
mission of the show it's so much of what
this show is all about and i recently
had the honor of surprising an
incredible teacher from chicago who's
going above
and beyond for her students
please take a look at megan
hi my name is megan ferdi i'm a pre-k
teacher at schubert elementary school in
chicago and i've been teaching for eight
years teaching preschool is really
special and unique because every day
looks different everything is really
hands-on and we want everything to be
really tangible for the kids the way
that i teach is very emergent and child
led that means no two days look the same
part of the magic of preschool is that
kids are so curious they are naturally
explorers and when you can foster that
and facilitate it every day is really
exciting i have learned so much working
in the chicago public school system and
have seen a lot of things that are
amazing and wonderful and i've also seen
a lot of things that i think need to
change our school does the best they can
as far as supplies go but everything we
use is consumable so
we are running out of supplies all the
time teaching is a wonderful beautiful
job where i get to work with amazing
kids the impact that you can make not
only on academics but on students social
emotional well-being and having a safe
space and building a community in your
classroom makes me really proud to be a
teacher
i don't mean to scare you but i
i might scare you
hi megan
[Applause]
how are you
great how are you i'm good it's so nice
to see you
i know that you're responsible for this
hallway yeah well i think you picked
really beautiful colors thank you we
have um
such amazing kids and this building is
pre-k k
so
we you know my principal and i had
talked about it we wanted to reflect the
kids and for them to be a part of it and
they even had a say in picking out paint
colors and stuff i love that and all of
these like banners and stuff that you
see those are all different book covers
so we had different features pick them
out and design them we have
five pre-k classrooms and two of them
are dual language classrooms i have
every one of these books so that's what
makes me feel so
cozy and happy being in here as my
two daughters
frankie's now in first grade and olive
is in third
and
i just miss the days of preschool and
kindergarten i'm so interested in
why
you felt that education was so important
because i was reading that you didn't
necessarily
think maybe when you were a kid you were
going to be a teacher is that true i
actually went to columbia college
chicago which is an art school that's
right so i had initially gone into
painting and just kind of to fulfill a
credit took an education class and
the professor and the course and the way
that they viewed children as so capable
and
the magic that i got to see in preschool
classroom i was like this is it do you
ever feel like i feel like my kids are
like a fresh start like there's so much
hope this formative shaping and time is
so crucial and important to them
i'm learning law and policy so that i
can work in advocacy for children and
families within the education system
interesting yeah so you can advocate for
families and children
within the education how are you finding
the time to do that it's a lot of work
but it's work that i love i'm really
enjoying it for right now for sure well
i love your intentions and i love your
life choices and
i love that your path has led you
to these
places so much we had such a beautiful
day together before the break we met an
amazing chicago teacher named megan who
had the pleasure of surprising her at
her school but that wasn't the only
thing we had in store no no much bigger
and more important things take a look
i love being in this part of the school
because well there's this aspect
[Applause]
everybody wanted to show up to say
that they support you honor you love you
i can't thank you guys enough for
showing up for megan today so that she
can see that
shannon please come up talk to megan
this is your sister i'm like a fly
i think you're a huge inspiration to not
only me but everyone here you know is an
older sister
you are one of the most you know
compassionate and understanding people
ever you've taught me so much just about
myself and about education you know
i think that as a teacher you an
educator you inspire me um
seeing how much she works with your
students and just
you know how much you give back and your
selflessness is something that i don't
know i if i get in like a small bit of
that as a teacher i call myself lucky
when you came to schubert's school you
walked into a classroom where the
children went through six different
substitutes and nobody wanted to stay
with that class of children because they
said they were rowdy and two weeks later
i came in to your room and it was a
carpet just like this and the children
were all seated
in front of a screen and they were all
signing in sign language what a
wonderful world
and the thing is megan is that you
not only stayed at schubert you saved
those children those children needed
stability and love and a person that
would be there and be dedicated for them
and that's what you gave to them i want
to invite us all to sit down because as
you sit down luckily something else will
happen too
this is one element of today joanne
stores is gonna donate um ten thousand
dollars worth of art supplies
and they also want to give you
ten thousand
[Applause]
for
dollars
megan
thank you as well thank you and so much
joanne stores
and you know i have to say when you
talked about how when kids um
uh when they just don't have that
stability in that structure and they're
craving it and you know whether they're
your kids personally
or not like where do you
drum up the love and compassion and the
time and the commitment to get in there
what do you summon inside of yourself
that could teach us all kids are really
capable
and
if we give them the space when they're
having those big behaviors or they need
support in that way um there's no such
thing as a bad four-year-old or a
five-year-old or six-year-old they're
communicating to us that their needs are
not being met it's also about trusting
kids and listening um and not just
walking in a room to teach them but
being really open to what they can teach
you i can see how you make people feel
safe and
that is one of the most powerful things
we can have in this life of great
uncertainty and maybe that's why we need
it so much
so thank you for
being who you are by the way i'm really
sorry if i smell like hot dogs that just
came from jimmy's
and i had two hot dogs and i'm like
well megan what do you think um that
your first art project is you're gonna
attack with all your new supplies and
your kids you know i would have to ask
the kids
well thank you guys so so so so much
thank you thank you so much it's
unbelievable thank you so much for
everything
megan thank you
thank you for all that you
do
[Music]
you